now the families of those caught up in
the nineteen eighty four minus strike at
all grieve have demanded a full
investigation into allegations of police
brutality there the Home Office had said
it would announce whether or not there
would be an inquiry by the end of
October well here we are and they're
still be no word well Andy Burnham the
former shadow home secretary in
Manchester mayoral hopeful has been
campaigning for such an inquiry and
joins me now from his constituency in li
very good morning to you mr. Burnham so
uh not long left in October for this
decision do you do you think it's not
going to happen well no I hope it is
going to happen we need a decision and
we're expecting it tomorrow and in my
view the case for an inquiry is
overwhelming and undeniable now I've got
nothing but praise Dermot for the way to
resume handled hillsborough but you
can't be selective about which things
you look at and which things you don't
if you look at the evidence trail from
hillsboro it leads very directly to the
door of Orgreave this is the same police
force using the same tactics five years
earlier in the case of Hillsborough they
sought to deflect blame of the Liverpool
supporters after or grieve they did the
same with the miners so you know people
need the truth it's a reasonable request
and I make this last-minute appeal to
the government today please don't let
people plead for the truth they deserve
it order an inquiry into or grieve
tomorrow so that we can all understand
what happened draw a line and then
hopefully move forward and wide-ranging
I mean you mentioned the parallels with
Ellsbury I want to get onto south
yorkshire police again in a moment or
two but a similar kind at similar
configuration for the inquiry yes I
think so because Hillsborough in the in
the original phase had a panel that
simply disclosed the papers that were
held by the state Dermot and provided a
commentary as to how that disclosure
change things now the reason I'm
standing before this camera today and
talking to you as I promised those
Hillsborough families the full truth and
I don't think they can have the full
truth until we also know what happened
five years earlier in the aftermath of
all grieve it's the view of the chair of
the hills
Family Support Group Margaret Aspinall
that if South Yorkshire Police have been
held properly to account after or grief
or what they did then the cover-up over
Hillsborough might never have happened
and that is why this issue is so
important it's also important to be
honest though to heal the rifts that are
still there in mining communities one of
the the miners who was at Orgreave Kevin
thorne writes a very powerful piece in
the newspapers today saying that you
know he wants his grandchildren to trust
the police in the way that he was
brought up to do and if that is to
happen that does need to be this process
of reconciliation and what about South
Yorkshire Police we mentioned quite a
lot there in Hillsborough and previously
in or greed there are those now saying
well south yorkshire police should we
look at perhaps getting rid of them
amalgamating them with another force
well I think we need to have full
disclosure don't we about the past and
if necessary people held to account I I
pay tributes actually to the current
leadership the police and crime
Commissioner for his willingness to say
well we're ready to look at or grieve
and open up over or grieve but that that
needs to be done together with the
government so that we get the complete
picture it is crucially important isn't
it to the people of South Yorkshire that
we repair trust in their police force
I'm not necessarily calling for it to be
abandoned altogether but i do feel it's
unfair to those men and women who are
out there today on the streets of South
Yorkshire trying to keep people safe to
have these clouds of the past constantly
hanging over them the only way you can
get rid of those clouds is to say we're
going to have this inquiry we're going
to give people the truth and the justice
that they need and then hopefully as a
community we can move forward together
now mr. Burnham tell me about your
ambitions have become the mayor of that
well beefed up Manchester part of the
northern powerhouse extra money more
powers do you feel though that their
current administration I mean those
ambitions came namely from the previous
Chancellor George Osborne do you get a
sense the current administration is
cooling on the northern powerhouse a
little there's a lot of talk of the
Midlands engine these days I have
nothing against seeing the Midlands
regenerate too but
there were specific commitments made to
the northern powerhouse in the
conservative manifesto and in my view
they must be honored but also this
policy is is the right policy i pay
credit to george osborne for being
perhaps the first chancellor to talk
seriously about the north but the big
danger for the Tory party is they plated
a cravat clever slogan here with the
northern powerhouse but they may end up
seeing nothing behind it all spin and no
substance so yes we need to see the
government put their money where their
mouth is and they need to start actually
at the Autumn Statement you know we've
been trapped in this long debate on
Heathrow dermot which is kept the focus
on london and the south-east people
appear as saying what about us what
about transport in the north they're
still trundling on packed trains over
the Pennines it's not good enough so i
want to see a clear timetable in the
autumn statement for what it's called
hs3 east west high quality high speed
rail i would argue that is the single
highest transport investment priority
for this country linking the great
cities of the north I can't see how the
government can justify going ahead with
Crossrail to before that it's our turn
now surely and we need to see that
investment coming to the north of
England but on becoming a mayor of
Manchester you also need to see don't
you from the government the primary
legislation it hasn't been passed and I
was reading an interesting piece the
other day one of the blogs so many of
them I'm saying that why on earth would
a Conservative government that seems to
have nationally seems to have labor on
the run create these powerful mares in
northern power houses like Manchester
when they remember the lessons for
instance if Ken Livingstone and the old
GLC in the 1980s Margaret Thatcher got
rid of it because he was a thorn in her
side why would they create new thorns do
you think they will actually go through
with it that's an interesting question
isn't it but I hope they do because
actually it's the right policy that's
why they should go through with it it
wasn't actually conceived erm as the
answer to the referendum and brexit but
actually it should be embraced as such
now because what I think the referendum
result brought out was a cry for change
from many parts of the country that feel
abandoned that don't feel Westminster
has worked for them you know we've had a
situation in national politics where the
London perspective has dominated
national policy so when areas like mine
here wanted help with manufacturing
industry all of the national focus was
on the service sector when we wanted
help with affordable homes to rent
council housing all of the focus there
was on right to buy an owner occupation
and when we needed help with skills and
technical education the national focus
on the University route that's why
people feel the country hasn't been run
for them and that's why immigration
surely was a part two but of course
there's a deeper sense of of
disillusionment here so that's why the
government shouldn't abandon this they
should press on with it it's there it's
the time to deepen the commitment to
devolution in England and in me they're
not going to have somebody who is kind
of party political for the sake of it
picking fights I'm doing this I'm ready
to leave Westminster because I want to
devote myself to improving the lives of
people here rebalancing our country from
south to north that's why I'm doing it
if the government will work with me then
I will work with them well before you
leave Westminster what's your views on
the Richmond Park by-election you
mentioned Heathrow and we all know that
spark that by-election with zac
goldsmith there resigning to stand again
as an independent and there are those in
your party senior figures in your party
suggesting that Labour shouldn't stand a
candidate well because I haven't really
got much of a chance of winning it and
also to bolster the chance of the
Liberal Democrats to embarrass the
Conservatives my main view on it is it's
quite an indulgent act on the part of
zac goldsmith you know there's a pretty
significant price tag that comes with a
by-election and and what happened Dermot
to the old way of doing politics where
everybody debated things and had their
disagreements but when the party made a
decision that was the decision and
people then you know having had the
argument should have been there to
accept it so I kind of find it's a
distraction and actually again it will
it will keep all of the focus on
Heathrow on London on the southeast when
actually the focus should be up here
looking at the unacceptable transport
system that we have got so I personally
always take the view that labor should
contest by-elections we shouldn't give
the other parties of free run for narrow
tactical reasons but you know that's
just my that's just my view but my
overall I just think this is a huge
distraction when the country needs
baguette
the job of making sense of what brexit
means and arguing for a balanced
breakfast that protects the economy that
that's where our focus should be now not
having pointless by-elections got the
last question on that mr. Burnham I mean
flowing from the nissin a decision and
guarantees or not we don't know for sure
given to Nissan and its investment in
its Sunderland plant if you become mayor
of Manchester of course many many huge
exporters in and around the region who
will they be wanting would you be
fighting for for similar guarantees post
brexit that they wouldn't suffer extra
tariffs if it is a hard brexit
absolutely i mean i'm not against at all
the government helping a key company in
the north but they can't just do one
deal for them and leave everybody else
with nothing so the same surely Dermot
has to apply and you know we need to
know exactly what has been promised here
because there has to be a sense of
fairness doesn't to all companies in all
parts of the country and that's why I've
been arguing actually that as well as
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
having a seat at the table at these
brexit discussions Greater Manchester
needs one to Merseyside needs one west
and south yorkshire you know we can't
again have a situation where the London
perspective besides the terms of brexit
you know we need to hear the voices from
around the country so that we get a fair
brexit that works for everybody and I'll
be arguing very hard actually that a
hard brexit will hit the poorest parts
of the country the hardest of all I
challenged resume in the Commons about
this on last Monday and I said to her
you know has she looked at what the hard
brexit would do to the North West of
England and I said if she hasn't done
that analysis isn't it very
irresponsible to be burning our bridges
with Europe and talking up a harbor exit
and her reply was amazing because she
said I've never said I favor a hard
brexit what that tells me is she's
confused actually about where she's
going right now she's been ramping up
the rhetoric and actually when she went
to the European summit last week she
found Britain very isolated and very at
risk actually from from the rest of
Europe walking away from us so I think
the Prime Minister has got off to a bad
start on all of this and she needs to
get back to talking about a balanced
breakfast that yes responds to people's
concerns
on immigration but does not see our
economy sold down the river all right
and did you vote for you mate ed balls
last night I didn't son fortunately I'm
well impressed and his moves they were
never that good on the football field
that have to say I played up front
alongside him and he didn't move that
quickly then so I don't know what
they've been doing with him but it looks
impressive i have to say and you know
fair plates whimper doing it might be
you sometime you never know Andy Burnham
very good to talk very much as that's it
I view them